California is known for good wine and
Italy is known for good wine so we
decided to bring in three Italians and
three Californians to settle once and
for all who has the best wine California
or Italy I'm ultimata emotive OCHA oh
that is just awful
I've never had wine so bad I'm not I'm
serious
Christine Vichy no no Stan Taylor Garcia
pew pew fresco the charming woke up you
psycho this is basic and this is like a
road Scholar
Kristen paparazzi doula a popular for
respectability nice huh I like this one
more this one is a little bit too bitter
for me California no italiano this
tastes like maybe it was grown in a
drought California italiano Americana
and this one Italian it is done quickly
tadhana Christian up now we're onto the
white wines in California we call this
water crystal of you who us towards our
good and pop you that is an assault of
flavor crystal Adam anything support a
dino daughter this one seems like it
would go good with food the Italians
love food Californians don't like to eat
christop el italiano Chris economize
California no please get down I think
this one's a California I think I
deserve a drink
Christopher italiano requests economy
camera this is the Italian one and that
this is the California wine but I'm
choosing this one as the better wine
I like it better yeah
smells like something my mom would drink
Camello Dora and Kimbo carries automaton
cuantos echo is great smooth it's like
almost buttery light and fun offensive
hey baby una de guerra de su nebula
whatta respect oh I think I like this
one better
it's just a little brighter pristine
body Verona Posada off of smell alone
I'm gonna think this is the Italian el
americano Ecuador amia sinistra
I think this is the Italian and this is
the California quest italiano personal
Italy definitely kick out for his ass
the state says no Reba drive in
California party we will do you Barbera
probably meant on Turin California
stress Parma men take a so no to TMS on
Sawadee pensive oh you know all in all
the Italian wine seemed more enjoyable
but if you want a cool funky label
California is your place I am curious
I've been spitting out my wine this
whole time I'm gonna see what the
concoction tastes like this is all six
wines together you know you're gonna say
I'm crazy
this might be the best one this is good